[Musique]
mais merde on a appris la bouteille en
partant excusez moi monsieur
ouais je ne connaissais pas un arabe pas
loin ouais j'en vois vraiment pas loin
ah ouais bah vous voyez pas non voilà à
deux pas grave
ah bah tiens et si vous cherchez un
indien lui il va sûrement pouvoir vous
aider non mais on a déjà mangé nous on
veut un arabe bon ben si vous voyez pas
je suis désolé mais je peux pas vous
aider tous les mêmes qui va ou non mais
vous qui m'avez dit que mon attention
j'ai l'habitude vous allez pas me
laisser ma vous les parisiens pas nous
aider là oui c'est un peu cliché mais
vous n'êtes pas sympa bon reprenons 1 0
ok je me présente je m'appelle hakim
lounès achour et vous cherchez un arabe
vous l'avez ou pas bon laisser tomber
c'est sur ma route vous me suivez
c'est la merci des [ __ ] c'est super
dur de trouver en europe en coin un
moulinet moi je suis là et la vidéo
allez fini tu peux tu abonnés à la
chaîne que tu sois noir bleu jaune grand
petit attend un meuble ou n'existe pas